okay one of the things that we have been
kind of
discussing
we i mean me with many in the audience
is how we should react to the deaths
of the unvaccinated or more specifically
the anti-vaccine individuals
anti-vaccine individuals who prominently
say we're against the covet vaccine and
then they die of covet
i get emails all the time
from people saying david you really
shouldn't gloat about anti-vaxxers dying
and i agree i don't gloat about
anti-vaxxers dying i've said time and
again i feel terribly about people who
have been misled into thinking the
vaccine is a bad thing and then they get
covered and then they die and their
family members grieve and it's sad i
don't gloat about it but this is super
interesting there's a column in the los
angeles times
by michael hiltzik
which says
we should be mocking anti-vaxxer deaths
and it is a fascinating read we will
link to it and i encourage you to look
at it
michael writes
among all the ways that covet affects
our lives the pandemic confronts us with
a profound moral dilemma how should we
react to the deaths of the unvaccinated
on the one hand a hallmark of civilized
thought is the sense that every life is
precious on the other those who have
deliberately flouted that's not flaunted
remember that's a word flouted sober
medical advice by refusing a vaccine
known to reduce the risk of serious
disease from the virus including the
risk to others and end up in the
hospital or the grave
can be viewed as receiving their just
desserts
that's even more true of those who not
only refuse the vaccine for themselves
but publicly advocated that others do so
it has become common online and in
social media for vaccine refusers and
anti-vaccine advocates to become the
target of ridicule after they come down
with covid and especially if they die
from it witness the subreddit herman
cain award
um
the site is named for the former
republican candidate for president who
became one of the first political
notables to succumb to the disease after
publicly defying social distancing
measure measures like another site sorry
anti-vaxxer the subreddit hosts snippets
and photographs of anti-vaccine
advocates often taken at their deathbeds
the issue of how to think about the
deaths of unvaccinated has been thrown
into high relief locally by the case of
kelly earnby remember we covered that
that's the orange county republican who
was against the mandates and died of
covet unvaccinated
ernby's death promptly came to symbolize
the rift in the social fabric caused by
the ravages of covet and then it goes on
to say that some of what is happening
with her is bigotry and hate
michael hiltic has a different take he
says to begin with let's stipulate not
all unvaccinated people are alike some
are unvaccinated for legit medical
reasons children for whom the coveted
vaccines haven't been ruled safe for
someone with a real medical reason some
may have faced obstacles in getting to a
vaccination site others may have been
may have refused the vaccine because
they've been deceived by fox news or
whatever else the deaths are truly
lamentable finally there are those who
have voiced public opposition to the
vaccines not all of whom are
unvaccinated themselves ernby was in
that category she asserted opposition
not to vaccines but to mandates
and hiltsick goes on to say
it should be clear that opposing vaccine
mandates as a as a substitute for
opposing vaccination itself is a
fundamentally incoherent position it's
little more than the garden variety
small government republican ideology
hiltic points out the significantly
lower vaccination rate
of republicans
and says
mandates do work
requirements that people provide
evidence of vaccination have been
associated with heightened vaccine rates
as for whether vaccination mandates are
a slippery slope to more government
control which many of these people
maintain
government mandates for vaccines have
been with us for decades and for other
kinds
wearing seat belts having airbags in
cars banning smoking in public places
and that these mandates exist because
the diseases threaten not only the
infected people but also the community
and hiltic goes on to say
uh ultimately
that it is so pernicious that we have
these people around advocating against
vaccines or against vaccine mandates
that in fact we should be ridiculing
them that in fact we should be mocking
them and that in the long run even
though it feels like a ghoulish thing to
do
the same way that vaccine mandates work
mocking those who are anti-vaxx
uh
outspokenly anti-vaxx or anti-mandate
and then die
actually is effective at getting people
vaccinated that it might feel wrong as i
have said and many of you have said but
that it is actually a necessary thing to
do because of the public health
consequences check out michael hiltzig's
opinion piece and i would love to hear
from you about this uh let me know what
you think
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality bio
available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything i'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes